how does one become more likable other
than by reading Carnegie well first of
all don't fake it canigas got this great
phrase which is you get more people to
like you without becoming genuinely
interested in others than getting them
to becoming interested in you people are
fascinating you've got something to
learn from everyone you meet so develop
that genuine interest I don't you can
fake likability or as you can but maybe
not for very long when you go to a
website it's a bit like meeting another
person do I trust that website is it a
likable website does it help me to
achieve what I'm trying to do is it
straightforward I think all the
attributes that we decide about humans
we're actually applying to websites and
we have these websites we visit again
and again like the news and they become
like an old friend the trust is
interesting does it be like sort of
blowing up the balloon isn't it over
time you trust somebody but only takes
one moment of them lying to you and that
just vanishes so it's this thing which
is quite hard to get sort of reputation
yeah it really matters